All right, let's bring up our next
guest. How you doing? Hello. You a
Muslim? Very good. Yes, I am. Awesome.
Awesome. You uh how long you been a
Muslim? My whole life. Your whole life.
Okay. Born into it, raised into it. Yes.
All right. For sure. Was So, what have
what have you heard about uh like
growing up in Islam about the Quran's
preservation? What has been the like,
you know, what's common knowledge as
someone who's born is 100% preserved.
And actually, you would not be a Muslim
if you didn't believe that. You can't be
a Muslim if you don't believe that the
Quran is 100% preserved. Yes. So, even
if you believe that maybe the Quran had
some changes or some variance or
whatever, but maybe it wasn't like it's
not 100% preserved letter for letter,
but it's relatively preserved. You can't
you can't be a Muslim and believe that
it's relatively preserved. What do you
mean relatively preserved? Like let's
say let's say you have a Muslim that
believes that there are some uh like
like a Muslim that doesn't believe that
every word has been preserved like there
there are some variance but you know the
message is the same basically if you're
if you're talking about the different
readings of the Quran that does exist
and we also do believe in those okay but
you have to understand that if you're
going to say that there is like 10 or
seven readings readings, you're going to
claim that those are different Qurans. I
would say that's wrong. I would just say
that back on in in Prophet Muhammad
days, there was different tribes that
spoke different dialects. And actually,
it makes sense for the Quran to be
pronounced differently. Okay. So, you're
saying that these aren't these aren't
really these aren't different words.
These are just different ways to say a
word, how to pronounce it. No. Even even
if it does have some words that are
different, Mhm. M it just completes each
other. Okay, I got you. So that the
meaning won't change. Yes. Okay. So what
if there are meaning changes in these
varants? Would that mean that the
Quran's not I guess perfectly one or
preserved? No. As I said like even the
meanings they complete each other. So
there can be different meanings but
still but complete each other. Yes. How
so? What do you mean how so? I mean for
example I know this one. I'm not I'm not
an expert in the other readings of the
Quran, but for example, there's one
example from the first chapter in the
Quran where instead of saying
um which is the owner of of the day of
judgment, it says the king of the day of
judgment. Now, I I don't I don't see
that as being like uh a totally
different uh uh realm, you know. I I I
see it as just uh God is the owner of
the day of judgment and he is the king
of the owner of of the day of judgment.
Yeah. And we submit that these are all
Quran. These are all parts of the Quran,
you know. And you're saying that Allah
said both when he revealed the Quran, he
said both of these things. He said both
king and owner. No, we we say that
Prophet Muhammad uh uh read it to his
companions that way. So yes, we believe
it's also part of the Quran that Allah
has revealed to Prophet Muhammad 100%.
There's an example that I I use um and I
would like your thoughts on it. It's
it's in Sahafat chapter 37 verse 12.
Wait, chapter 37. Let me see. Chapter
37:12. Um I know it's late for you guys.
You guys still good? It doesn't look
like the guy we wanted is coming. Yeah,
we're um Yeah. Yeah. Uh we're good. We
can stay a little longer. Sure, no
problem. All right. All right. It's up
to you. You guys can um I'm I'm throwing
you guys the live, so jump in whenever.
Okay. Okay. So, you said chapter 37
verse what? Verse 12.
Mhm. And how would you It said it says
um you were surprised and they mocked.
Right. Right. And so this is Allah
speaking to Muhammad about how he was
surprised when the disbelievers mocked
and ridiculed the revelation. Right. Now
you have another reading that says
instead of as as right there it says too
where Allah says I was surprised while
they mocked. Now would you say that that
changes that that's complimentary or
would that like completely change cuz
it's changing from Muhammad being
surprised and Allah being surprised
about the mocking? Now I'm I'm not sure
about the existence of that reading to
be honest. Which reading specifically is
that? It's Khalif An Hamza and Alakasa.
Let me uh I'll show it on the screen in
just a second. Hold on. Let me pull that
up for you. Pull that one exactly up.
You could.
As I said, I'm not really an expert in
the difference uh the difference between
actually I've been reading the Quran and
and only one my whole life. Most Muslims
do I I I have it over here on the right
side of the screen. I I hope it's big
enough that you can see it.
Um right here. Can you see it?
And this is uh translate to English.
Well, you're Arab, aren't you? You know
what means? It's
like I I I am surprised. So Allah is
speaking here. He's saying I'm
surprised. So something like this, you
can agree changes the meaning
completely, right? Like I said, like
they both don't mean the same thing or
work together. Interesting. We have
there's a few things like this, man.
There's a few examples like this where
cuz I understand what you're saying
where there will be some variants that
even have a a different meaning that's
not like out of the scope like what you
brought up. Both of them can work king
or owner they both can apply but this is
I will not I will I will note this one
down you know for personal research for
sure. It's from Hamza. You know
your This is Yes. I've never read I've
never read and Hamza though. Yeah. You
wouldn't because everybody really read
Huffs, but it's there. And you can't say
No, no, no. I like like I think Northern
African countries read. No, they don't.
They don't. Yes, they do. You're
thinking of wor. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I think
it doesn't matter. You said to us it was
dialects. We're trying to tell you it's
not dialects because it's different from
you to I
pronouns changes from well the thing is
the thing is like again I'm not an
expert. Yeah, we know you're not an
expert. We're not an expert either. We
just read it like we just read. Okay. So
I borrow this from brother. So the thing
about the thing that is that not
everybody agrees that all of these Qurat
exist. Oh so this Quran doesn't exist.
So, how do you know the One second. So,
how do you know what the Quran is and
how can you define it if you all all
can't agree what exists and what doesn't
and what is Quran and what isn't? That's
a problem. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But
it it just it differs on like some
things are like certain 100% without a
doubt and some of the things are a weak
weak resource and weak uh naration. So,
I thought the weak thing was only hadith
that can be the andah and now you're
saying now you're saying
Yes. When it comes to Yes. So, you're
saying some are weak and some are
strong? I'm not really sure about that
to be honest. Okay. So, if you're not
sure, please don't lie because I'm not
because you're just Okay. So, again, I
keep I keep I keep referring to this. My
whole life I've only been
reading. Don't give fatwa if you don't
know. Like, we we we keep having people
saying can you can you can you just
Yeah, I know. But it's just I'm sorry.
I'm frustrated because Muslims keep
saying we're not scholars and then you
just
declare. That's really bad, my friend.
You can't you can't do that. I didn't
declare nothing. I just said that I
heard something like this. Where did you
hear it from? I I can't even remember to
be honest. But again, I
will because some people hear us and
they can be because you're talking to a
big audience. You're not just in your
house. People can hear it and be misled.
Some Muslims can hear it and think,
"Yeah, some are live." Don't do that, my
brother. If you're using just some
stranger that you don't even know on the
internet as as a resource to get misled,
you're already prone to do that in the
beginning. People do it all the time,
bro. That's why we're very Exactly. So,
but we can we have to control what is
being said on this platform. We have to
make sure it's truthful. Yeah. And most
people saying we're not a scholar.
I I see where you're coming from. I see
where we're coming from. Yeah. So, if
you're not a scholar, don't act like a
scholar. Just talk on what you know.
Yes. Can we agree on that? Okay. Sure.
Sure. Thank you. Thank you. All right.
The of there's nothing wrong with it. Is
it? It's one of the canonical readings,
right? It's one of the canonical
readings. Do you know what canonical
readings are? No, I do not. Please
inform me. Okay.
You see, I give it to someone else who
knows. Yeah. So, you know who I mujah
is? No, not really. Okay. So, Ibujah, he
was the the one actually. You mentioned
seven readings first, right? You you
said that there's seven, then there's
10. You mentioned that earlier, right?
Yeah. I'm not I'm not sure if it's
actually seven or even 10. Yeah. Yeah.
So Iben Mujahed was the one who
introduced the seven and popularized the
seven. Okay. Okay. So part of his seven
we're showing you these are the ones
when we say when we say canonical we
mean these are the ones that the Muslims
accept like these are the words of Allah
and even Muslims will say that they're
like they say that they're they're all
like you can't you can't doubt them. And
and then later later in time another
scholar Jazzari Jazzari came and about
like 500 600 500 years 600 years later
and he added three more readings and
those also now are considered like
they're all considered even though he
didn't believe that about himself. He
didn't believe he himself didn't believe
that these Qurans had this mass
transmission. He thought that there's
different ways to prove it. But Muslims
today will tell you that these are we're
just telling you what the scholars say
that these are all accepted. These are
all the word of Allah. But we're showing
you that there's Everybody is agreeing
on this. Is that Is that what you're
saying? No. No. There's no Sunnis that
disagree on this. No Sunnis who disagree
on this. You're Sunni, right? Yes, I am.
Yeah. So, there's no Sunni who disagrees
on this. Uh now, now when it comes to
what we're talking about, whether
there's differences and how these
differences affect the meaning. This
might be new to you, but there's a lot
there's a lot of variants that change
the meaning. even legal rulings. Some of
them will give different uh different
legal rulings based on how you read
them.
Okay. So, there's a lot of examples like
can you give me an example where like
other than this one they just gave that
like makes a huge difference in in
rulings? Yeah. Okay. Sure. No problem.
So, I can give you I mean I have like
three examples that I can give you, but
I'll give you I'll just give you one
right now cuz you're asking for one. So,
and can you like pull it up too like the
same way you just did with the with the
Yeah, no problem. No problem. We have it
on the screen. No problem. All right.
One second. Here we go. Okay. So,
chapter 2 Bakra chapter 2 verse uh 184
and Huffs and it's 183 in W and other uh
readings. So, uh this one it's talking
about what do you do if you miss a fast,
right? So if you're traveling or you're
sick, you're on a journey or you're
sick, what do you do to, you know, make
up for the
fasting?
Yes.
No. Do you see the mayor? Okay, let's
try to zoom in on you.
me. Okay. Oh yeah, there there's the
alf. I see the alf. Yeah, you see that,
right? And then then look at this one
here. God logic sees the alif. So mskin
me, right? You see that? Okay. So this
one gives you a different legal ruling.
Okay. Which which means basically
instead of feeding one mskine, feed
multiple. Exactly. So this changes the
meaning like if I'm going to make if I'm
going to break like if I if you're a
Muslim and you're fasting and let's say
you get sick one day or you're traveling
so you don't fast. Well, how do you make
it up? How can you redeem it? Well, if
you're reading one Quran, maybe you'll
you'll just feed one one poor person.
Well, that's why we have the Sunnah that
explain the Quran. Okay, but you asked
us for a difference now. You're not
saying what does the sunnah say which by
the way there's different rulings on
different um like mab will will differ
they differ on these things too you know
that they have different legal rulings
themselves so sometimes they'll use
these different readings to justify
their rulings now this is a particular
one where if you miss a fast as a Muslim
you don't know how to make it up okay
well do you feed one poor person ms or
do you feed multiple messen which one do
you do well it depends on which Quran
you're reading that changes how you
practice Islam and well there I think
there is there is another uh verse wait
on this topic on this topic yeah it
doesn't matter though because this is
the verse that we're talking about so if
you're reading this verse and you are
asking the question what do you do to
make up your fast it depends on what
Quran you're reading to what you don't
you don't make a ruling just based on
one verse you you have to take it all
the this is what the scholars do though
the scholars go to this verse and
they're arguing about it based on this
verse Yeah. Well, the thing the thing is
the thing is if if we both believe that
Allah is the all just, the all merciful
and he and he observed the way these
scholars uh came up with this uh ruling
and it was legitimate. They were
sincere, they were honest with it and
they they looked at it from uh all the
resources that they had and they came up
with this ruling after um after studying
it properly. Okay. And and then some
people followed that genuinely like
we're not saying you're not genuine.
We're saying do you believe that Allah
revealed to Jirel to reveal to Muhammad
one time saying ms and another time
saying no the the point yeah the point
the point is is that you asked for for a
reference to show okay give me an
example of something that gives you a
meaningful legal difference. This gives
you a legal difference and now you're
saying oh we don't base it off of a
verse. So why'd you ask me for a verse
in the first place? The fact of the
matter is is that you do have scholars,
the jurists, they do base rulings off of
verses and they go to the Sunna as well.
You're right. I'm not saying they don't,
but they use these verses to determine
the rulings. And some of them will
argue, not just on this verse in
particular, I'm just using as an
example, but other verses, they'll say,
for example, okay. Okay. But actually,
if you look at the they'll say they'll
use these readings to make their
rulings. So the different Qurans give
you different legal rulings. So how you
practice Islam changes based on which
Quran you're reading. No, no, no. It it
doesn't it changes based on the way you
look at the at the sunnah. How the
sunnah explain the Quran and the way
prophet Muhammad what comes first the
Quran or the Sunnah? Both come together.
You can't is your is your biggest
authority and you say to us Quran is you
say oh it because because you could
never you could never distinguish Quran
with from the sunnah because we pray
five times. It doesn't matter that's
that's not relevant. The point is is
that the scholar is very relevant. What
do you mean? No, no, listen. The
scholars go to these verses. The
scholars go to these verses to make
legal rulings. Okay. So, don't don't
pontificate on a topic that you don't
know about. These these verses are in
they're baited amongst the legal
scholars. So, you asked us you said give
us an example of where there's a legal
rule and that's a difference. This is
okay. Okay. So in in the in
the you could say you could see
here right. Mhm. So it says that if you
uh give like uh as volunteer if you feed
as a volunteer that would be better for
you. Yeah. But it says why why wouldn't
like another another verse it says the
same thing on the other side. It also
says give to lots of as well. It also
says you can volunteer but you still
have to give fidia for lots of so anyway
you're getting away from the point. The
point is that these two variants give
you two different meanings and these are
different legal rulings. So that's what
you wanted. That's what you got. We have
other examples if you want. Yeah. So the
point is it's not dialect my friend.
It's not dialect because msk and mak is
singular and plural jama. That's not a
dialect. That's different. Mhm. That's
our point. Your Quran is not about
dialect change difference. You said
tribes and all that stuff in the
beginning. What do you claim it is about
then? Sorry, what's that? What do you
What's your claim it is like what? Okay.
Do you think he says for what? For for
the difference in in the rulings. No,
no, no. What you're asking for? Yeah.
Okay. Okay. So, you you claim that
there's different versions of the Quran.
Is that Is that what it's in front of
you? Yes. It's in front of you. We we
started with andu you didn't like that.
You said you're going to find out. You
said it couldn't be canonical and then
we found out it was canonical. You said
you show me legal rulings because you
were trying to say okay it can't be that
bad. It is that bad. There are lots of
examples. So your point is you have
different Qurans in Arabi. You don't
have one Quran everybody knows and
everybody loves and word for word and
letter for letter just different
dialect. That's a lie my friend. They
told me that same lie when I was growing
up and I also didn't know. Same as you.
and and you are now what? Doesn't matter
to you. We're Christians. We're
Christians. Christians. Christians don't
hide behind the truth. Christians don't
say from them from the from the pulpit.
We have I don't either. I I just say
that I I have I haven't really heard the
Islamic you're a victim. You're a victim
of their lies. They lie to you. Like
they lie to you. No, it's just it's just
like I've never really came across this.
Uh yeah, because you didn't need to come
across it cuz we just believed it.
Everybody said I will look it up. I will
look it up personally from my own trusty
way with all due respect to your kind
self, but I still don't know you. I
don't know your We have the you have the
sources on the screen here. So, give us
an example of something that you want.
The other guy said theological
differences. You said legal differences.
We have the examples of legal
differences. How many differences will
it take for you to change your mind and
say, "Hey, someone lied to me. All these
different Quran are telling me different
things." Listen, it's it's like like
impossible for you to to change me from
Islam. Well, that's stupid. Well, that's
stupid, my friend. Because you come with
the personal insults. I don't I don't
think that's It is because if if I give
you the I I haven't really called you
any any disrespectful insult. So, don't
let me ask you something else. What's
the point of you asking us for examples
and evidence? If you say there's nothing
you can say that I'm just really
interested in seeing what you guys have.
Yeah. Well, you're interested, but you
ask for evidence when you don't want to
change your mind. Then you're a waste of
my time. Then go believe the lies that
you want to believe. Then don't ask me
for evidence and then say nothing you
can say can change your mind. You want
God to come to your bedroom, Jesus
himself to come to you and say I am I am
I am God and then you say no matter what
you say I won't change my mind. Well
guess where people like that end up.
People who saw the miracles of the
prophets and they said no nothing you
can you can say can change our minds.
People like you I advise you to change
that and say if I see evidence I will
believe. If I say if I see enough
evidence but like this is not enough
evidence. Well what's enough evidence?
We asked you. We asked again I I haven't
I haven't heard the the Muslim scholars
that I trust. Hey, you didn't say enough
evidence. You said no matter what you
say, I won't believe. That's what you
said. Oh, let me let me ask something.
Let me ask. So, when you're saying that
you're you're going to look into it,
what does that look like? What is it
when you look into these issues? What
does that process look like for you? Go
ask u my dad, my uncles, my the same
people who told you the same the thing
that we just debunked. So, well, I will
just look keep looking further until I
find an answer because I've always had
the answers. I've always like What's
your name? What's your name? How do I
say it? House. A WS in English. Okay.
Okay. Nice. So, look. So, you say you're
like you you'll ask your dad, you ask
your uncles. Like these are some elders
that you trust. Yeah. That they that
know a lot. You know, they know much
more than I do. Yeah. So, they're
knowledgeable in your eyes. And so, when
they trustworthy, right? And so, when
they and and and this is and if they
tell you and I'm going to tell you what
they're going to say, I'm not a prophet,
but when they tell you, "Oh, yeah, man.
you know, it's just different dialects
and it was revealed, you know, in both
ways. You know, it's just the dialect.
They haven't really changed the meaning.
And you bring this up and they say that.
What would your mindset be when they
give you that response? Well, they
haven't really given me the response
yet. I know. I'm saying, what would you
do if they gave you that response that,
"Oh, yeah, it's just dialect. It all
means the same. It all goes back to the
prophet. We believe in all of it. No
problem. It's not a different Quran."
Well, that's not going to happen.
Probably. Probably. Got you got to have
a lot of faith, huh? So, look, I my my
my door is always open um for people
who, you know, who take this stuff and
they go back and they ask their elders,
ask the imams, shakes, family members
that they trust. I want you to come back
and tell me what they told you and let's
see. I got I got two examples for now.
You gave me the uh the uh the example
from Bakar and the other example
from Right. Yes. Okay. I will find these
two examples and come back. All right.
Also, I'll be looking for you, man. Sure
thing. I'll be waiting on you, man. I'll
be waiting. I want you to come back.
Don't let it be too long. Don't let it
be too long. So, wait. You mean you mean
come back like right now or? No. No. Not
today. But I'm live Monday, Wednesday,
Friday. Monday, Wednesday, Friday are my
normal live live stream days. So, at
this at this hour also. Yep. Yep. Same
time. So, I would love for you to come
back and tell me what you found and we
could talk further. Okay, sure thing.
All right. Well, I appreciate you coming
on, man. You were patient. I appreciate
you taking the time to look at what we
showed and noting it down. I I
definitely appreciate that. Sometime I
will definitely be looking at this for
sure. For sure. All right. You take
care, man. God bless you, bro. See you.
See you. All right. Well, I think that a
seed was planted and that's all we can
wish for and hope for and that and that
God grows and waters if he chooses to
and uh you know, we'll see what happen.
Let's pray for him. Amen. Let's pray for
him. List break for one.